hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to let's play slender
the arrival I was able to get right back
into where I was because there's a stage
selection mechanic that left off right
after the eight pages chapter name which
was only part of the beta but now we are
finally getting into the new stuff and
you guys suggested that I soak up the
atmosphere and then I was like what was
I doing
what do you mean since you just soak up
the whatever whatever the fans know best
so I must abide by their suggestions hmm
I can feel it okay screw that I'm out
here let's go forward skipping so
lollygagging Lee through the daisies and
see what's in here
I can smell these no okay got a move
forward hello I can't seem to move in
this oh hello there's a page what do we
got here number five oh I've missed
number four I mentioned it to my doctor
again when I saw him today he really
wants you to come in sometime just to
talk with him I think it's a good idea
he also said they're confronting this
traumatic event in some way could be
very beneficial to don't worry I didn't
tell him any specific about what
happened I do think we should go back
out to that park behind your mom's house
sometime soon
I think being out there and sings
nothing will help get rid of these
stupid problems we both having see our
item added to my scrapbook where's my
scrapbook anyway oh I can toggle that
but anyway I must have missed numero 400
somewhere in the beginning at least I'm
hoping at least I I'm hoping it wasn't
in the house I was pretty sure I cleared
all the rooms of the house out but I may
be wrong I love the way this person just
skips as she's running I think is she I
believe it's a she there's something on
this rock or something this is a
suspicious truck but I can feel the
texture okay no time for that
gotta keep moving forward
the grass smell so good I'm so in
soaking up the environment okay
cha-ching a little will chew into this I
need to calm down I couldn't get into
that place so serious I love this is
just skips heard a noise alright I told
I kind of forgot that I was playing a
slender game for a moment there I do
have to admit this whole environment is
incredible I really love it I mean I
know that's probably a skybox in the
background but it's really well detailed
everything about this is just really
immersive and makes me feel like I'm in
a gigantic forest in the middle of
nowhere which I'm assuming is the idea
okay there's
I feel I feel compelled to move this way
now and a suddenly I am from New Jersey
yeah
alright so hey wait what's this I see
you know is it number four no it's
number six poopy I tried to find my way
back to you when I tripped and fell down
that slope but my flashlight hit one of
the rocks down here and broke it was
bits black I heard sounds all around me
screaming it sounded like you I tried to
follow it back but I was lost I fell
everything collapsed down around me
I could feel it crushing me everything
was moving so fast I was drowning in
water I couldn't see every fear I've
ever had came back to me at once
monsters surrounded me my stomach
inverted my eyes shriveled into out of
existence and my heart caved in I don't
know what happened after that I woke up
in some tall grass today and found my
way back to the house I looked through
the window and saw you sitting on the
couch staring at your TV I couldn't get
your attention so I left I can't read
anymore I can't think straight I need to
eat what after coding this Sunday your
paychecks will be made to your home
address that we have on file for you
please see Jessica in the office blah
blah blah final paycheck dedicated
service to Coleman mining and wish you
the best of luck in your future
endeavors
ah so this place is thoroughly shut down
is what they're trying to say and other
than that I'm going to go into this
abandoned place to try to discover some
monsters Suey
where'd my flashlight hand go my hand
disappeared it's probably just in the
darkness it's awfully echoey in here so
why am I going into the abandoned mine
who knows I don't know do you know cuz I
do not all right I can feel the echoes
echoing within my sari none I'm undone
absorbing the environment oh hello all
employees must be removed from the mines
via emergency of lift as soon as
possible inventive sudden power loss
their six generators are the minimum to
require to power the lift oh crap you're
kidding me
I got a power I am okay Kate the woods
are beautiful please come see I'm
going to find you so you can see if
there's so beautiful Kate you're gonna
find Kate hey okay righty-ho
alright so things are getting a little
weird between those two local parks
sells land to Coleman mining Co now it
was old and I have a feeling I'm gonna
be on another hunt down here trying to
get generators fired up hello oh I can't
go back here well it's kind of a dead
end isn't it
he's bricked up walls nothing I can do
about that unless I had like some
dynamite or something
is this a flammable oh is this an
exploding barrel maybe I could have find
something else maybe there was something
else outside that I missed the note set
oh my goodness you're kidding me how did
I miss that are you joking me what done
oh did I miss this are you kidding me am
I really that big of an idiot
god I am stupid okay the arrows are
pointing me in the correct direction I
am I am so dumb okay here we go that
took way too long
okay oh that is not good this reminds me
very much of penumbra in the mining area
that may just because it's a mine but at
the same time I got that eerie feeling
that something's not gonna go right in
here it's kind of like slender the eight
pages but a little bit of a different
mechanic don't know huh
any place would need six generators
seems like a bit of overkill at least
they're close together Oh goodbye go
away please
Slendy are you down here and you down
here you [ __ ]
i schooled you when I picked up all your
crummy kindergarten drawings yeah I know
you had to repeat the first grade nine
times
you're so stupid I'm so smart I'm so
smart to make a fun of the murdering
entity that's trying to kill me then
again it might not be [ __ ] that's
after me right now it might be um one of
his cohorts I'm sorry I made fun of your
stupid drawings they were really quite
good for an idiot
sorry I overloaded the mic again [ __ ]
Alice I gotta stop doing it I always
have it close to me when I'm talking
these bowls of Teletubby custard oh come
on the first three generators were right
next to each other where's the other
three [ __ ] I see a red glow over there I
can't run I better just cool my Jets
okay don't look back
it's first lesson don't look back I went
upstairs and I didn't see anything why
wouldn't I see it
there must have been something up there
lest why would I be suffered the same
insanity of with I am
I didn't know was that masky I think
that might have been masky um
oh we're loading the mic again I don't
leave me one more generator so let's go
I don't know what the hell that was
I don't know what it did to me either he
like jumped on me and did you start
whaling up my face I don't know why or
why or why god damn it get away you son
of a [ __ ] mother of God
stop it up in here already
oh no not again you go away you little
[ __ ]
you'll hit it prick I mean it's gotta be
upstairs I hear you where are you where
are you damn it oh not a girl you want
about chart you - aah - get away from
him I can't run are you son of a [ __ ]
you mother your mother
Zack
I only need one more generator but I had
no idea where it was
I've been all over this place it don't
know where to go all right whatever
I probably my price been way too much
time just kind of standing around doing
nothing so let's just go this way now
must be at the end of this hallway it
would make sense unless it's just loops
back around somehow I don't know either
way the other three were real close to
each yeah this just loops in a circle
maybe there they're probably randomly
distributed oh no I don't know I don't
know maybe I got lucky
was this a need to get out yeah no
kidding maybe I just got lucky with the
first three being right next to each
other the other ones I was talking about
penumbra too much jeez I mean gosh dang
it oh no they're right here again first
3r oh no wait no okay they are random
there's only in one there
I gotta stop sprinting everywhere
because I need to save that for one
Slendy and I'm guessing masky or trying
to murder my face off I guess I get one
try with masky and I got a real close
call there was Slendy I mean I thought I
was done I thought I smacked right into
him but apparently not oh no you do not
oh no you do not oh you back up little
kid I will all I will slap you so hard
no no no no no no no no I know I know I
know little kid I will I will punch you
in the balls
I'm just going in the complete circle
yeah I hear you spread her battery up
there you stay up there
uh-huh it was wrong with your throat
buddy that was not fair there was such
bull you kidding me what the hell
god this is so stupid you a-holes trying
to nibble my giblets and it's not funny
Sonny can't just pop right in front of
you that's not fair that can't be fair
all right I got a hurry or something I
don't know what I gotta do but I gotta
get this done quicker and I have in the
past all right now there are none down
here good great
wouldn't want to make it too easy on me
all right let's just clear the entire
upstairs first and then go downstairs
got it
good plan team break this is either
harder this is harder than the eight
pages just because there's two things
after me which isn't fair it's not fair
it's not fair I say and I says a lot
all right stop running for a second I'm
clearing the entire upstairs before I
move downstairs that'll make it easier I
don't know just so long as Sonny doesn't
poke his dick in my eye right off the
bat I'll be fine
so far so good
ah see this is what happens when I plan
accordingly
I find the second one and I sub four to
go yes let's keep going upstairs cuz you
never know there might be four upstairs
oh wait no there is no more upstairs to
go to so I guess I just got a drop down
here yes ah super epic barcoo roll oh no
you don't you [ __ ] oh you get out of
here oh you get out of here I hear you
this seems new what is this oh no wait I
saw this okay you little I hear you you
get the eff out off piss where are you
where are you running at where are you
running that little kid
AHA got number four I'm the greatest
where are the others ah you get away you
little kid oh no he's gonna give me a
mullet of Sprint juice I'm out of Sprint
juice run died right behind a stop at go
I go I owe ya it's not so weird
hi I can't run away from him I got nuts
print baby he's right behind me
just go away you little [ __ ] just shut
up shut up shut up shut up shut up shut
up just shut up I'm gonna lose you on a
drop off shut up shut your mouth
I can't running so slow shut up shut
where'd you go
oh hi Sonny where'd masky go did he
finally decide to leave me alone you
know I hear I'm still pitying up there
that's a little son of a [ __ ] I can't
get away from him all right I just got
away from him so I guess I can get away
from him but at the same time I still
need two generators and I ran through
like oh right listen for the fight of
their stocks stocks all right I don't
know what the hell is going on I better
get the downstairs Bert I don't you know
I don't even know because this doesn't
make any sense
I'm making on jingdong damn stretch how
the hell am I supposed to be able to get
away from the little kid I did it the
first time then like never after that
again I don't know I don't know I don't
know I don't know but that little kid is
annoying I'm gonna try to like click and
spam fight him off me or something I
don't know all right so I'm gonna try to
well let me just wait here's another one
oh you are already already with for
being a douche
no see the little pitter-patter of feet
is usually a such a happy sound but in
this case Oh with that you're gonna come
up here huh wha that's why I thought get
out of here you don't wanna mess with me
I'm wait to throw well I'm gone fast now
why did I suddenly get a big burst of
speed
no no why but I suddenly went really
fast okay that's for that's doing good I
got four but I was able to get five the
first time and I didn't hardly did
anything just look for the big red glow
I guess oh he's right behind me isn't he
not yet he's not ah I forgot about
Slendy I forgot to worry about him I was
so caught up with masky that I totally
forgot that's Lenny oh he's right there
huh yes
he's gonna get me he got a gap I oh did
he go the wrong way I think it went the
wrong way
good hello Rick ah
scratching my chin not fair bro I was
scratching my chin that is so not cool
man
oh now I get a burst of speed why do I
occasionally just get a random burst of
speed
I mean I like it but why okay I just
need to get I bet it's in one of those
two rooms down there open how do I get
down there I'm going the wrong way I'm
going the wrong way up here Savage why
am I going this way this is not the
correct way what am i doing how do I get
back down [ __ ] it you know what I'm
actually I've never been this way I
don't think so let's double check maybe
I bet it's in one of those rooms over
there but I don't know where this is oh
okay I got it okay I got it I got it I
got it I got it I want to know how I get
the super burst of speed I know oh oh
you little [ __ ]
no wait did I make it where am I God you
son of a [ __ ] you stupid a-hole
I'm not crawling on the ground get up
come on just one more come on I can do
this I'm a slender bro
con just stop sprinting for two seconds
and then just go but don't run into
Slendy because that's counterproductive
oh but I'm so slow why am i fast why am
i slow when am i faster no oh please oh
please oh please oh please no oh so
bound it's down here please be down here
oh he's right there ah-ha Lindy's
guarding it no you said of a [ __ ] it's
right there I need that go away go away
both of you go away you're guarding it
why your son died all your mother [ __ ]
come here you [ __ ] ah [ __ ] now you
don't get off the night that's right get
away okay not crawl on my belly yeah oh
ah he's broken my both my legs but I'm
too badass to even be fazed by it how
did I miss this I went by this place
before
okay now please go I can't I don't even
sprint faster than I walk this is for
goddamn Nicholas everything about this
is just for goddamn Nicholas no both of
you back off I'm done I'm getting out of
here
you both f off
I'm done okay I'm done I'll get this
later all right okay all right okay I'm
done for now so thank you all so much
for watching click the annotation for
videos that I've done and as always I
will see you in the next video
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]